was you know my producer McKenna loves
nothing more than to compile videos of
the most annoying people on the planet
videos that will make me see with rage
here we have I'm informed toxic women at
the gym on Tick Tock let's start at the
top
I was doing my squats you know popping
that booty she belongs to the street
and directly behind me happens to be a
man on the treadmill I heard him say I
just want to say one this is not a
personality this is a this is not that's
not a what is this no person talks like
this so this is someone with no
personality who's who's trying to do an
imitation of what she believes a
personality is and she but she she has
constructed her personality from memes
that she's seen so this is someone who's
taken a bunch of memes and cobbled them
together into her imitation of what a
personality is and this is what you end
up with crazy crazy woman uh continue
look I can walk on a treadmill and get a
show to his friend that was on treadmill
hey you know what I did you know what I
did what I turned around I stared
directly into his soul and for a solid
minute I just inched closer to his
machine
[Music]
him he was so uncomfortable I made him
leave
I'm so empowered
I have no doubt that she has the power
to make people leave rooms
[Music]
so if that's a power that she's taking
pride in then I have no doubt except
that that didn't happen Okay so that
story is as real as her personality this
is The Tick Tock thing where you record
things that are happening or better yet
something happens and then you record
your reaction to it later because you
didn't do anything in the Moment Like if
you if you're the kind of person who
handles things in the moment then you
don't feel the need to brag about it on
Tick Tock later that is what you do when
you're too you know non-confrontational
and too meek and mild and cowardly to
actually do anything about it so so that
didn't actually happen now if it if it
did happen
yeah that would be you don't say that
that's a that's an inappropriate thing
to say if it actually happened but one
thing you notice when we see the video
of it actually happening in every single
case actually the guy didn't do anything
wrong
it's not nearly as bad as it's being
portrayed so the the really egregious
acts of sexism are always the ones that
somehow didn't get caught on camera and
we're always the one the ones we're told
about later are the ones that are the
most egregious which is interesting
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing will soon no
longer be the world standard which will
be our greatest defeat frankly in 200
years there are three reasons the
central banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars political and economic
upheaval dating all the way back to
Biblical times and that is gold I've
bought gold from Birch gold in
preparation for uncertain Economic Times
and you can trust them too you can now
own golden a tax sheltered retirement
account with the help of Birch gold
that's right Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket the currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have you can
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold is an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau they have thousands of
happy customers I'm one of them if you
want to be one of them you can text
Walsh to 989-898 to get your free info
kit on gold again text Walsh to nine
eight nine eight nine eight today all
right let's move on to the next one
[Applause]
to begin with why are you recording
yourself at the gym what are you doing
with this video
um why and assuming the context that's
provided there is accurate which is a
big assumption because it says in the
video that he had come over multiple
times and she said I don't need help so
we're assuming that all that is true
then yeah the guy was a little bit pushy
but he was also trying to help I was
just trying to help you're trying to
help yourself more like he's concerned
you know you're you're bench pressing
free weights with no Spotter and you are
a woman what's that supposed to mean
well I mean using a bench press at all
as a woman is like it's that's not even
an exercise you really need to do in the
first place but especially free weights
doing without a spotter is that's
dangerous
so he's uh he's trying to help you out
now you could say well he wouldn't have
done that if it was a guy probably not
but men are more protective of women
which is a good thing
easy Miss I've got you and if you think
that's a bad thing you're not gonna like
what the world looks like when men don't
have that instinct anymore and in fact
we are we are rapidly becoming the sort
of culture where men don't have that
instinct anymore because when they act
on that instinct they're treated like
this they're publicly shamed shame Shame
Shame and so you have more and more men
and we're like fine whatever you know
what if the bar crushes your neck it's
your problem that's the world you're
gonna create and you're not gonna like
it so much okay next one yes
see all the guys that go to the gym for
the love of God is if a woman is at the
gym and she is getting her workout in
please do not come up to her mid step to
try to have a conversation clearly I
just got back from the gym but I
actually ended up leaving early because
I felt so uncomfortable with how this is
going and I'm not one of those girls
that like cries oh my God this guy's
looking at me like no leave people alone
like I don't believe in bullying men at
the gym either but it is really
uncomfortable when I walk into the gym
and I don't have like anybody else with
me and I dress like this when I go to
the gym like I dress like every other
gym girly so I don't want to hear from
people who are like oh well the way that
you're dressing is kind of asking for it
no it's not Becky I live in Houston
Texas it's 92 degrees outside and
there's barely AC at the gym that I go
to like I walk in and the minute I walk
in like I already see this dude like an
eyeing me down and I'm not like again
I'm not saying what his intentions were
he could have like all good intentions
but it's uncomfortable right okay all
right oh you're uncomfortable when uh
men are looking at the gym well then put
some damn clothes on it's not hard Jacob
put your clothes on I don't want to hear
oh it's in I'm in Houston it's hot I
live in Tennessee okay I live in
Nashville it's hot and humid here all
the time and uh and somehow I still
managed to be fully clothed when I walk
out of my house you can do this I'm
telling you I can't I'm so hot look
you're fine okay
that is a burden that I'm able to carry
the burden of my own clothing is
something that I can in fact most people
can so you you claim that you have to be
naked when you're walking at your house
well do you look around you do you
notice that most people are wearing all
of their clothing so they're able to do
it just
she says oh it doesn't mean I'm asking
for it no but you are actually you are
asking for the attention of men you are
literally asking for it you are begging
for it that is the only reason why you
would walk out of your house dress like
that like you're not wearing a full
shirt you're wearing your underwear and
here's the thing when you ask for
people's attention you cannot control
all the time the manner of that
attention or who precisely is giving you
attention when you walk into a room in
your underwear you're gonna be getting
attention from a lot of people and you
might think well I'd love to get
attention from him him and him but not
that guy that guy that guy and that guy
doesn't work like that because they all
have eyes and so now you're getting
attention from all of them you don't
want that then put some clothes on
pretty simple everyone
wear your clothes when you go to the gym
[Music]